in other news federal health officials
issued an unusual public warning about a
growing number of cases involving a
polio like illness mostly in children
acute flaccid myelitis or afm has now
spread to 22 states 62 cases are
confirmed 90% of the cases involve
children the symptoms often include
severe muscle weakness or paralysis dr.
Tara Narula shows up shows us why this
surge in cases is so concerning and Tara
this gets scarier by the day it does
it's rare but certainly when you hear
about it it's very scary for parents the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention says the numbers jumped
between June and September
health officials want parents to know
the symptoms because early diagnosis can
help doctors get a handle on the disease
every day Jenna Shumpert and her
three-year-old son Hunter do exercises
to help strengthen his muscles they use
electric stimulation pads to help
rejuvenate his damaged nerves Hunter's
illness came on suddenly when he was
just 15 months old initial symptoms work
off congestion runny nose and he had a
fever less than two weeks later Hunter
was hospitalized on a ventilator at this
point he was paralyzed he could not hold
his own head he couldn't sit and he
couldn't stand neurologists confirmed
Hunter had a FM acute flaccid myelitis
the CDC started tracking cases in 2014
when it counted 120 nationwide outbreaks
appear to follow in every other year
pattern they jumped in 2016 and there
are now 386 confirmed cases we don't
know what's causing this increase in a
FM it is truly a mystery disease while
symptoms are similar health officials
have ruled out any connection to polio
or West Nile virus for some of the
previous cases we've identified one
pathogen or another but we have no
unifying diagnosis Jenna Shumpert says
hunter has regained some strength since
his diagnosis but his future recovery
remains uncertain nobody really knows
treatment protocols they don't know
prognosis and they can't really give
parents an answer as to where this is
coming from doctors say well this
disease is rare it is serious with one
death reported last year it just breaks
your heart to see what hunter and his
mom are going through can you give us
more specifics about what parent should
be on the lookout for so many times it
can start with what looks like a
respiratory illness and a little bit of
a fever and really the hallmark is
sudden onset of weakness in the arms or
the legs children can also have trouble
swallowing trouble with their speech of
facial droop trouble with their eye
muscles but the most feared and most
dreaded concern is when it affects the
diaphragm the muscle that helps us
breathe that's when children can really
deteriorate and end up on a ventilator
and we know some children can recover
and some have not sure parents be asking
their doctors about this issue
definitely I mean early intervention is
definitely always helpful and
unfortunately there's no real treatments
that have been proven to work but early
rehabilitation has been shown to help
and preventive measures so getting
vaccinated taking precautions against
mosquitoes washing hands all of these
things are what's recommended by the CDC
yeah never go wrong washing your hands
repeatedly and kids and not adults is
very scary stuff Thank You Tara very
much